you know how back in the days miners
would sift through dirt and sand and it
would take them days
hours until they finally struck gold and
then they would celebrate and they're
excited about it because they finally
found gold
the same exact way that miners would
mine to find gold is the same way you
got a mind through
you for ideas you got a minor ideas
there are ideas in you and in your group
of friends
that you got to draw out that's like
pulling out content right people say
how do you guys come up with new content
on valuetainment we mine
to find content out so last week i'm in
las vegas
we're at the mgm grand arena we're about
to shut down the convention next few
months we're gonna have 10 or 15 000
people there
and we're at hakkasan we're looking at
all these places i'm having
breakfast with matt sheena hector
rodolfo hart
palayo and secret and we're showing this
new content that came out
for the seminar called sls sales
leadership seminar sold out within a
week
it's going to be held in breakers in
south florida and i'm going through
every way that i've built a
sales team how to build a great sales
team and how to drive a great sales and
there's 10 elements to it
we're going to cover that together i'm
not selling the ticket to it sold out
i'm sharing this with you because when i
show the content they ask the questions
how how'd you come up with this content
and i said we have a system for how do
we come up with content how do you do it
i said well
we'll sit there in the boardroom okay
and we'll
need markers we need a board and we need
a couple people that know the history
know the content
and we'll start asking questions the
next thing
we start putting stuff up what do we do
first what do we do then what do we do
this
said i don't get it can you tell me more
it's a great okay so let's do a quick
exercise here
i said can you guys tell me what
sheena's strength is
so he says something you know hector
says something rodolfo said something
you know pallaio says something hart
says something
it's okay sheena i think your strength
is dot dot
i said the part about your strength that
i believe you have is you're the best at
studying and processing getting feedback
from somebody
your speed to execution it's so
incredible
i've never met anybody that's as fast as
you in executing
speed from getting the idea buying into
logically convinced
you're not emotionally convinced you
have to be logically convinced you move
like this i've never seen anyone that
moves that quickly
then it's okay what's my strength so i
went through hector's strength then we
went through rodolfo string
we went through everybody's strength
right so
palayo's strength what is it you're a
great teacher you know you're very good
at delivering this okay rodolfo what's
yours
and finally we get to matt sapolo matt
over he was the ceo of the company and
sheena being the chief chairman of the
board of the field advisory boards i
said that's apollo what's his biggest
ring
so they're all saying their own comments
i think it's this i think you said i
think it's this
and i said i'm gonna i'm gonna say two
strengths that he has one of them
he can teach the other one you cannot
teach and you're gonna see how this
twist of events
of my story leading to this that has
nothing to do with mining content but
everything to do
with mining for ideas right i said one
of my biggest strength is the following
number one uh his attitude is infectious
you know when you're like looking for
signs of success oh my gosh it's
let me see how this guy does it oh it's
got to be such a technical thing
half the battle is having a great
attitude because a great attitude
attracts other good people in your life
that give you ideas and you know
strategies that work for you right
i said this guy's got a ridiculous
attitude i see you know matt you know
what i'd like you to do he says what's
that
i'd love you to go and write down 20 to
30 points on why you got such a great
attitude
and he's like uh so i said sheena you
got to pull it out of them and then
others got to pull it out of them you
got to be thinking about it then you got
to transfer to people because a great
teacher is what
somebody that knows how to transfer
knowledge to him somebody who knows how
to transfer knowledge to you somebody
knows how to transfer knowledge to billy
the ability to transfer knowledge and
strategies is what makes somebody
a good teacher yes storytelling is
effective yes getting you to see it in a
different way to say oh this kind of
made sense
no one ever explained this to me before
we just talked about this in a video a
couple weeks ago
but then i said there's a second key to
him
and i said here's what it is they said
what's that and by the way most of the
guys at the table have it not all of
them
but couple the guys at the table she has
vargas most of the guys at this table
have it right
and he says what is it i said you have
to realize
um you know how you see some people in
your life where like how does this guy
go on four hours of sleep wakes up and
goes back and it's like
how do you stay so excited and you're
fired up throughout the day how do you
have all this energy
where does this energy come from i said
there are certain people you can't teach
them
so what do you mean i said well you
don't know
why this guy's not stopping nobody knows
the real story why
we kind of can speculate say maybe it's
his relation with his dad maybe it's his
relation with this
maybe it's what happened in high school
maybe it's an ex
maybe it's a former boss maybe it's a
former business partner running a former
company what you can combine all those
things together
but there will be certain people in life
that have had such
high octane pain
in their lives that they had to go
through that
their their reasoning to want to prove a
point
cannot be explained to the average
person
that they can't stop for they just can't
stop they're going to continue to go
until this thing becomes a reality so
what's your point here's my point to you
yesterday went on a call a girl named
jasmine asked me a question
great at what she does she asked me a
question she says pat
you know how do you know at what point
you know for people to not slow down on
their vision and continue how do you
know when somebody gets at a level to
not get comfortable and all this other
stuff i said look
almost everybody can get to a certain
level 50k 100k quarter million a million
whatever the number is
i said the people that never stop you
don't have to tell them to never stop
like they don't read a book on how to
never stop
they don't read a book on how to
continue going
they don't read a book story came out
yesterday about julius randle
and espn was telling the story that
julius randle when he was playing with
kobe
told him hey one rule of thumb when you
go on the road he says what's that
before you go to bed always go to the
gym
and take a few shots before you go to
bed julius randle's like really says
yeah that's one of the things i've
always done
kobe says this so the girl's telling the
storm like where's she going with this
she said so julius randle's going to
play at the knicks at not at the next
he's playing at the
i don't know where he's playing he's
playing i wanted his play i think it is
new york he goes to play for the knicks
prior to going to the game he calls the
guys and says i need to shoot some shots
tonight they said listen everywhere is
closed
they find a high school they open a high
school up so julius randle can make some
shots
julius randle goes there the coach of
the high school team
is waiting for him it's like midnight
julius randle walks in
and to start taking a shot the coach
says hey man it's really great to see
you here we rarely have to open up the
gym
to take shots like this the last guy
matter of fact that did this
see this the last guy that did this was
a guy named kobe bryant
you see how many people you think kobe
said that story to before you go to
a game another city to play go to a
local high school and take shots
kobe's probably told that to hundreds of
people but the story we find out about
is through
a guy named julius randle who actually
did
what kobe told them to do the few people
that are still watching this
where you want to do something really
big in your life and we're trying to
pull out all this mining all this
content minding all this other stuff
there's one thing we can't mind we can't
mine the few crazy
absolutely insane obsessed people that
are not going to slow down
we will never fully know your reason
until maybe your biography is written or
you write your memoir and you open up
and tell us what the real driver is
because some of the reasons we're not
going to tell the world about it you
know exactly what i'm talking about
but those few of you that are still
watching this
i don't need to tell you anything
because you're not going to stop anyways
you know who you are
you're going to continue 90 of people
are still not watching this video
because they're like what the hell does
this have to do with mining for content
but the small percentage of people that
are watching this right now
hey um as long as you know your future
looks bright
you're going to experience some crazy
moments but you don't know how to stop
which means eventually we're going to
find out about you and read about you
and i can't wait to read your story one
day that's to the few by the way it's
not even one percenters
it's even smaller than one percent it's
a very very small
community of people if you watch tiger's
documentary you'll see like
where the drivers came from this guy to
go out there and become who he is and he
couldn't stop
stop talking to the guys we're sitting
i'm like you know what number scares the
hell out of tiger like all this mess
he's going through right now with
you know the accident speeding the crash
he just recently had all this other
stuff
everywhere he goes he sees one now he
can't get one number out of his head you
know what that number is
19 19 19 19.
he probably doesn't like guys with the
jersey 19.
he probably would never live in a
building where the address is 19
he would have a hard time beating anyone
at the number 19. you know what number
19 is
that's the number to be jack nicholas
and it drives him insane to see
that that may never happen with him as
much as he went so quickly
winning 10 12 masters everybody thought
he was going to crush
the number of 18. he may be at a point
right now
he's like i don't know if i can ever
break this it's very hard for guys like
that that want to break records and go
through it it takes a lot of phase to
kind of overcome that phase
because he's got that obsessive
personnel it's the reason why guy
changed the game nobody in the history
golf ever changed game like tiger tiger
did so again to the craziest that are
watching until the end
[Music]
life's going to be weird for you you're
going to experience some pain
but eventually if you stick it out and
do something big we're all going to read
about it
just won't you know about this we're all
going to read about it whether it's in
business
whether it's in sales whether you're
going to be somebody that your family is
going to have the picture on the wall
because you're the family that changed
the entire legacy
whether we're going to find out about
what you did in a company that took it
to the next level because you wouldn't
stop until you figured out exactly the
solution how to fix that one problem
that the company's had for the last
decade
and your obsessive personality finally
figured it out
either a community a family a generation
a city a state a country a nation
the globe is going to find out about
your story because you people like you
don't know how to stop everybody else
who watch this
was going to comment below and say
that's not healthy that's exactly why
people have so many issues because of
what you're encouraging people to do
i'm not encouraging people to do nothing
i'm just letting you know
there's a very small group of people in
the world that the world does not
understand
who don't know how to stop whatever you
tell them
whatever you give them they don't know
how to stop they're gonna get what they
want
or they're gonna you know this line goes
die trying they're gonna give their best
to figure out exactly what they want in
life and it's gonna be an interesting
journey
if you're one you're gonna enjoy it if
you're watching it you're gonna enjoy
the movie
having said that for the few the crazy
ones that are still watching this i got
a video for you but it's only for the
crazy ones it's titled
14 strategies to beat your goliath of
your industry as an entrepreneur may
have a different title if you've never
watched this
click here to watch that video and with
that being said have a great week
everybody take care bye